as you know well because you may be one
of them tens of millions of Americans
are now unemployed and running out of
money the rest have to worry about
losing their constitutional rights in
fact many of them are gone but one group
of Americans has no worry at all about
getting whatever they want the homeless
in San Francisco anyway officials are
putting up the homeless for free in City
hotels and supplying them with free
alcohol drugs and nicotine why are they
doing this exactly Joe Alioto was a
former San Francisco city supervisor and
DA Canada he joins us tonight Joe thanks
so much for coming on I can't think of a
clearer signal to taxpayers citizens
people try to do the right thing stay
sober that we just hate you and are
spending all of our time on people you
know who who are contributing I mean
honestly
people I mean why would they be giving
the homeless free stuff I don't
understand well it's not just that the
worst part about it is that there that
we are taking a very vulnerable
population and we're feeding their
addictions and we're not using taxpayer
dollars to do that which begs the
question why is you know where is this
money coming from and is the reason why
we're not using taxpayer dollars is
because it would otherwise not be legal
to do I mean we know that's true on the
federal level anyway
but the idea that the government can
poison a few people for the good of the
many is is it's immoral as this has been
debated over years it's unconstitutional
very unamerican for that matter and by
federal standards illegal which which
probably explains why some of the hotels
as you've read in the Los Angeles area
refusing to participate in the housing
of the homeless so the Los Angeles City
Council I know you're from North End San
Francisco he's threatened to quote
commandeer hotels that don't want to
become homeless shelters I mean just the
level cliches turn right I mean so and I
look I'm for helping the homeless so
many them are mentally ill and need
actual help they don't want to need to
live in the sidewalk but the level of
concern all the concern seems to be for
the homeless like what about people who
are trying really hard to do well for
their kids and make the society better
like they're totally ignored why that's
right especially with the food shortage
we should
feeding their stomachs not their
addictions and I guess they feel as
though the rest of us can fend for
ourselves but I think the real concern
here by the Department of Health to give
them a little bit of credit is that they
they don't want to spread the Cova
disease now the facts don't pan out
because some of these homeless people
who are being housed in the hotels that
are specific to this program that we're
giving them methadone marijuana and
alcohol some of them are not even kovat
positive but what they're trying to do
is force them into self isolation by
feeding these addictions and there's
there's something very wrong about that
these are people that are otherwise not
that legally detained but the city is
saying no no we want to make sure you
stay in these hotel rooms so you don't
poison other people and we're gonna feed
your addictions to make sure that you
stay there if there's there's something
very cruel about that and the fact that
you know we're not taking care of the
rest of the city and in many ways and
feeding some of the hungry people and
not focusing on the hunger issues and
not the addiction issues is is very
troubling I love San Francisco and I
want it to thrive but I'm worried that
at some point the only people left will
be the homeless all normal people will
have left I hope I'm wrong
I know you do Jake Joe Elliot oh great
to see tonight thank you thank you
Tucker